yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
tech channel of the week this is tech
channel of the week number four
and this tech channel is
tech tech man and yes that the name of
his channel does uh pretty much
represent what he does here on youtube a
bunch of technology related uh youtube
videos uh but this is his channel
youtube.com user techtechman i'll put
his link in the description and uh
basically what he's doing is um
uh he already is a youtube partner he
became a youtube partner back when he
had actually less than a thousand
subscribers and his channel has been
growing ever since and because of the
quality of his videos so if we actually
go open up his videos here you'll see
that uh the last videos or a bunch of
the videos he's done have been a mix of
hardware software a giveaway etc
um
so the last video he did was an app pack
and that was actually because he
recently did an unboxing of an ipod
touch i believe 2g so now that he has an
ipod touch he can do application reviews
maybe a case review i'm not sure but he
did a review of the ipod touch he did
the unboxing uh so he also has a macbook
and he does uh tutorials about uh the
macbook his uh startup and shutdown time
customizing his dock what's in his dock
stuff like that uh he also did a little
bit of hardware reviews of stuff he
already has like the uh the the
messenger bag he has and the minnie
mouse but most of the reviews or the
videos that you'll find on this channel
are uh application reviews now right now
he has a fifteen dollar itunes gift card
going on because of him reaching the 2
000 subscriber mark which actually
wasn't that long ago um and it's gotten
him a lot more subscribers so you should
definitely go check that out if you want
to be entered into his giveaway
uh this is the rest of his channel right
here he has 32 videos up and being a
youtube partner he can put a bunch of
recommended channels uh on his site and
i happen to be one of them yay me
so um
yeah he just reached six uh 4 000
subscribers a couple of minutes ago
which was awesome
so i definitely think you guys should go
check this channel out it's a tech tech
man again i'll put the link in the
description pretty simple channel got
the blue and yellow going on subscribe
today um
i think you like what he's doing and i
think you'll appreciate his content so
go ahead and check out his channel i'll
put his link in the description so you
can look at it and that is basically it
so thanks for watching guys and i hope
you stay tuned if you subscribed thank
you very much and uh hopefully you'll be
entered into my next giveaway which will
be coming up soon uh in honor of my 1
000 subscribers which i recently
achieved so thanks for watching this
video and have a nice day peace